hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
the main purpose of David hume's section
10 of his inquiry concerning human
understanding on Miracles is to argue
that Miracles don't actually happen and
that the testimony that is provided for
all sorts of Miracles throughout history
and by all sorts of people across the
Earth is not going to establish that
Miracles have actually taken place or
even that they will take place in the
future at the very end he says this also
applies to prophecy and so it's got a
pretty wide scope and at the end of the
first section of it he tells us that the
plain consequence is and it's a general
Maxim that no testimony is sufficient to
establish a miracle unless the testimony
be of such a kind that it's falsehood
would be more miraculous than the fact
which it Endeavors to establish he
actually concludes and he says you know
if the falsehood of a person's testimony
would be more miraculous than the event
they relate then and now till then can
he pretend to command my belief or
opinion now that's setting the bar
incredibly high and then Hume at the
beginning of section part two of section
10 is going to say in the foregoing
reasoning we may have supposed that the
testimony upon which a miracle is
founded may possibly amount to an entire
proof and that the falsehood of that
testimony would be a real Prodigy but
it's easy to show we have been a great
deal too liberal in our concession and
that there was never a miraculous event
established on so full and evidence the
evidence of testimony so you know he's
saying I gave you this this General
maximum or principle it's not actually
going to apply and I went too far are
with that now I'm going to bring out the
big guns and give you Arguments for why
there aren't any Miracles that have ever
been established on the basis of any
testimony whatsoever and this is kind of
a hodgepodge of of arguments they're you
know quite interesting they're more or
less independent of each other although
they do stray into each other's fields
to some degree and where he's going to
conclude is also kind of an interesting
place as well so the first thing is he's
numbering these off and he quits
numbering after a while he says first
there is not found in all history any
Miracle attested by a sufficient number
of men of such unquestioned good sense
education and learning so as to secure
us against all delusion in themselves of
such undoubted Integrity as to place
them Beyond all suspicion of any design
to deceive others of such credit and
reputation in the eyes of mankind as to
have a great deal to lose in case so
they're being detected in any falsehood
and at the same time a testing facts
performed in such a public Manner and
and so celebrated a part of the world as
to render the detection unavoidable all
of which are requisite to give us a full
Assurance in the testimony of met so
he's saying listen people can talk about
miracles we never get a report that is
coming from
sufficiently credible Witnesses who are
all in agreement with each other we know
that they're not going to lie to us or
anything like that so you know what this
means is that any miracle that is
attested there's you know in hume's view
something that we can pick at we could
question as he says the uh veracity
right we could question the Good Sense
the education the learning we could
question the Integrity we could uh
question whether they have bad motives
or anything like that we can always
bring up that with respect to any
particular Miracle now it's interesting
because a little bit later on in the
section he's going to bring up some
people who he says well you know if
anybody's going to believe it's got to
be these guys here but we'll we'll get
to that in a minute the second one is
much more interesting I think he says we
may observe in human nature a principle
which if we examine it will be found to
diminish the Assurance we might have
from Human testimony in any kind of
Prodigy anything that's that's really
strange that is outside of the ordinary
scope so this would include not just the
miraculous but also the mark marvelous
perhaps
he says the maxim by which we commonly
conduct ourselves in our reasoning right
so how we actually think through things
is that the objects of which we have no
experience
resemble those of which we have so we
judge things that we don't actually have
experience of
by what we do know and and this could be
you know ancient history it can you know
Hume earlier in the tree says well you
know we know how British people and
French people are so we know how Greeks
and Romans back at Antiquity are rather
somewhat dubious claim but nonetheless
he goes on and he says
um what we have found to be the most
usual is always the most probable
so where there is an opposition of
arguments we should give preference to
those that are founded on the greatest
number of past observations or best
confirmed we could say by experience so
what can we do with this now this is
where it takes an interesting turn
Hume is going to say how do people
actually behave what's our experience of
that
so he's going to talk about a number of
different passions things that people
are affected by and the first one that
he brings up so he's observing this in
his own time and saying well if it if
it's happening in our time must be
happening every other time the passion
of surprise and wonder arising from
Miracles being an agreeable emotion
gives a sensible tendency towards the
belief of those events from which it is
derived and he says this goes so far
that even those who cannot enjoy the
pleasure immediately who are not seeing
like the miraculous or marvelous event
love to hear about it ooze is that
really the case and he gives all sorts
of funny examples of this a little bit
later on he says the many instances of
forged Miracles and prophecies and
Supernatural events you know people like
this kind of stuff and he says this is
our natural way of thinking even with
regard to Common incredible events and
now this is kind of interesting to think
about is this something that happens in
our own time he says for instance
there's no kind of report which arises
so easily and spread so quickly
especially in Country Places and
provincial towns as those concerning
marriages in so far that two young
persons of equal condition never see
each other twice but the whole
neighborhood immediately joined them
together the pleasure of telling a piece
of news so interesting of propagating it
and being the first reporters of it
spreads the intelligence the juiciness
you might say of the gossip and you
might say well you know country towns in
hume's time maybe that's what was going
on I don't know about our present day
well they think about
banana shipping with fictional
characters ooh you know I want to see
these two get together when are they
finally going to as we say get a room or
get it on they're not going to get
married but they're going to fall in
love they're going to kiss they're going
to have sex right I mean maybe humans
really onto something there why do
people get so interested in that well
because of this surprise or wonder and
the agreeableness of the passion
there's another one he talks about the
spirit of religion right
so this is an interesting one as well he
says a religionist maybe an Enthusiast
and now an Enthusiast for Hume means
somebody who gives way to a kind of
fanaticism that really comes from their
feelings and he says a religionist May
imagine he sees what has no reality he
may know his narrative to be false and
yet persevere in it with the best
intentions of the world for the sake of
promoting so holy a cause or it could be
you know vanity as well right people
like to be the one who's in the know who
gets to tell us about the cool stuff
that's going on or another one
self-interest this is a big one as well
he says uh here we go self-interest with
equal force may be operating on human
beings so all of these different
passions can lead people to believe
things that they really have no good
basis for believing because they it
makes them feel good to believe it or
they want to believe it or it's going to
be good for them to believe it so that
is this thing that he's saying well we
see this this is part of our experience
so why wouldn't that be the case for
testimonies of Miracles so that's the
second argument
the third argument that he gives a
little bit later on he says
it forms a strong presumption against
all Supernatural and miraculous
relations that they are observed chiefly
to abound where among ignorant and
barbarous Nations or if a civilized
people has given admission to any of
them that people will have been found to
have received them from ignorant and
barbarous ancestors who transmitted them
with that inviolable sanction and
Authority which always attend received
opinions so what is he saying there you
know when a miracle happens it's out in
the boonies among those dumb people who
aren't smart enough they actually like
examine what's going on and he uses as
his primary case here this uh false
prophet Alexander he's getting the story
from Lucian of samsoda and you know we
should actually pause here for a minute
how do we know that Lucian who's the
only source reporting this is actually a
reliable witness given the fact that
Lucia himself is prone to talking about
you know Miracles and prodigies and
things like that he's actually a
satirist he's got an interest in
presenting things in kind of crazy ways
right so put that aside for a moment
um you know where is this this false
prophet in path lagonia you know where
the people as Lucian tells us are
extremely ignorant and stupid if Hume
says he'd been in Athens they would have
figured him out right away and maybe
maybe so right maybe there's something
to that and so you know we should be
skeptical of any sort of reports that
are coming from people that we consider
to be ignorant or barbarous whether
they're in the present or in the past
and he's got this really great line here
where he says you know it's strange a
judicious readers have to say on the
perusal of these wonderful historian
that's such prodigious events never
happen in our day and then Hume says no
there's nothing strange about that
people lie people lie in the present
people lied in the past so you know
they're again we're working off of our
experience of human beings
going on to the fourth this gets a
little bit tricky and convoluted in the
text he says I may add as a fourth
reason which diminishes the authority of
prodigies that there's no testimony for
any even those which have not been
expressly detected that is not opposed
by an infinite number of witnesses so
that not only the miracle destroys the
credit of testimony but the testimony
destroys itself now how does this work
why would a miracle destroy the
testimony so where humans going with us
is saying you gotta look at miracles in
relation to other reported Miracles and
they're usually used as part of what he
calls a system of religion and he's
going to mention a number of these
ancient Rome turkey meaning Islam Siam
you know Thailand right so Buddhism
China probably Confucianism is what he
has in mind he also talks a little bit
later about ancient Greek religion and
Roman Catholic religion and he says that
the Miracles
that each of these are reporting and
then basing their religion upon
they contradict each other
so you know if we only consider one of
them by itself without thinking about
the rest then we could be like well I
don't know maybe there's something to
that but if we think about things in
what we could call a comparative
religion perspective or world religions
is often how we talk about it we could
be like well you know if if this is the
case over here this over here kind of
contradicts it and so it destroys
The credibility you could say of all of
them he says every Miracle pretended to
have been wrought in any of these
religions
as its direct scope is to establish the
particular system to which it's
attributed so has it the same Force to
overthrow every other system they can't
all be right
in destroying a rival system though it
destroys the credit of those miracles on
which that system was established so
that all the prodigies of different
religions are to be regarded as contrary
facts and the evidences of these
prodigies whether weak or strong as
opposite to each other and these are the
numbered arguments you know one through
four that he's going to give he is going
to talk about some other stuff for some
other pages and among these going back
to number one
well what if we do in fact have credible
Witnesses he talks about uh tacitus and
Vespasian who's supposed to have cured a
blind man in Alexandria by means of his
spittle Vespasian was not into
miraculous stuff he doesn't like people
pretending to be gods and stuff like
that and then we get the Cardinal
Durants in Spain who himself doesn't buy
into Miracles and and you know tends to
be skeptical of it himself and then we
get this Abbe Paris a jansonist and even
the Jesuits can't confute him and so
what does Hume say in those cases well
and so here's where we have a different
kind of argument
we still shouldn't buy into these
Miracles why not he says what have we to
oppose to a cloud of witnesses but the
absolute
impossibility or miraculous nature of
the events which they relate this he
says in the eyes of all reasonable
people will alone Be regarded as a
sufficient refutation so even if these
other things don't apply we can still
say yeah Miracles just don't happen I
mean by by definition the miraculous
can't actually be the case and he you
know he goes on and says the wise London
very academic Faith with every report
what favors The Passion of the reported
you know some good other ideas in here
and then he says listen
here's the bottom line on the whole then
it appears no testimony none whatsoever
for any kind of Miracle has ever
amounted to a probability let alone a
proof and then even supposing it
amounted to a proof it would be opposed
by another proof derived from the very
nature of the fact which it would
Endeavor to establish it is it is
experience only which gives authority to
human testimony and it's the same
experience which assures us of the laws
of nature so we got to pick between the
two laws of nature which we have proofs
for
miracles which it'd be cool if they were
true but contradict the laws of nature
we're going to have to take the laws of
nature ultimately and say yeah there
isn't any probability let alone proof of
Miracles now he concludes with something
kind of interesting uh towards the end
talking about Christianity and we can
say does you may actually believe this
or not and the answer is no I mean if
you look at his other discussions of
religion particularly in posthumously
published Works Hume does not think that
Christianity is a true system of of uh
Doctrine or anything like that but he's
hedging his bets here he says our holy
religion meaning Christianity meaning
Protestant Christianity is founded on
faith not reason and it is a sure method
of exposing it to be put to such a trial
as it is by no means fitted to endure
and then he says I mean think about the
Miracles that are narrated in scripture
just the ones in the first five books of
the Bible
um you know here we have a book
presented to us by a barbarous and
ignorant people right so that's one of
the things he's brought up in all
probability long after the facts which
it relates corroborated by no concurring
testimony resembling fabulous accounts
which Every Nation gives of its origin
reading this book we find it full of
prodigies and miracles and he gives you
a whole bunch of examples and then he
says you know I desire anyone to lay his
hand on his heart and after a serious
consideration declare whether he thinks
the falsehood of such a book supported
by such a testimony would be more
extraordinary and miraculous than all
the Miracles it relates now Hume is
being a little bit duplicitous here he
actually does think that the Bible is
not a reliable source but he's saying oh
you know
wouldn't it be extraordinary for it to
be false and you know he goes on and and
he says that
um you know mere reason is insufficient
to convince us of its veracity whoever
is moved by faith to Ascent to it is
conscious now notice what else he says
of a continued miracle in his own person
which subverts all the principles of his
understanding and gives him a
determination to believe what is most
contrary to custom and experience that
sounds as if Hume is endorsing a kind of
fidaism he's actually presenting it so
that he can say in his heart of hearts
yeah don't buy into that the Miracles
that are supposed to be the basis of the
Christian religion Hume thinks that
they're no more uh likely or even
possible than those of other religions
and all of this logic would apply to
them equally so humans going to reject
for all of these reasons any sort of
Miracle being probable or being proved
by testimony of witnesses or even worse
of people following after them and
assembling these stories